if you choose to you may remove your
mask
the decision that caught a country off
guard
is now in full effect after a florida
judge overturned the u.s federal mass
requirement claiming the mandate exceeds
the cdc's statutory authority this has
nothing to do with public health this is
all about politics despite concern from
the medical world airlines quickly
rewrote policies so too did other
transportation networks like trains and
taxis
the decision could cut down on
aggressive behavior with more than 5 000
mask-related incidents reported to the
faa in the last 16 months
after numerous extensions the mask
mandate was to end on may 3rd to give
the cdc time to gauge how the ba2
subvariant is spreading it's dominant
and it's climbing in the northeast and
is expected to jump in the next two
weeks masking is the single most easy
high impact low cost
lowest adverse reaction intervention you
can imagine
while americans can ditch the mask it's
not cut and dry
masks will be required on all flights to
and from canada transport canada isn't
changing its policy saying decisions
will be based on the latest public
health advice getting that balance right
and showing how we're able to continue
to be patient as canadians and do the
right things that's what matters some
medical experts argue aircraft
passengers can be up to three times more
likely to catch covet 19. now public
health experts fear removing this
mandate prematurely could wind up
causing more harm i think it's a mistake
i think we're going to have a lot of
people getting covered unnecessarily
it's unclear if the administration will
file an appeal given the uncertainty
over the need for a potential future
mass mandate still the white house
confirms to global news even with mask
rules disappearing the pre-departure
test for air travelers into the u.s will
remain
reggie kinney global news washington